hi i've got good news uh the ng tube has
been taken
out of my nose and my gut because that's
what it does
if you don't know what an ng tube is it
stands for nasogastric tube
which means it's this horrifying device
that gets shoved into your nose
down the back of your throat all the way
through your sinuses and into your
stomach
and it sucks out everything that you've
ever eaten and it's good for when you
have like a battle obstruction because
it means that
you know you don't just get all that
food packed into this one spot and cause
your intestines to rupture
that's no good for anybody especially me
so that's taken care of
but we did a bunch of tests this morning
a lot of x-rays and a lot of scans
and some contrast to see if things were
moving through me
and it seemed like things were moving
through okay
which is good so the doc said we're
gonna take it out
and observe a little longer i'm still
not allowed to eat anything but
the doc said that if i can have a bowel
movement then everything is on the up
and up
you know what i mean because that makes
sense you can poop
then your intestines are working so
we're just waiting on that but i am
going to be in the hospital for probably
another night
just for observation so they can check
up on me and make sure nothing is going
to explode in my gut
which would not be good but it does look
like that i will avoid
surgery this time which is always a plus
so uh yeah that's it for now a little
bit longer for me in the hospital but
thanks everybody for karen
and uh you know i just really appreciate
all the kind wishes and also
i don't think it was the pop tarts i
know there's a lot of conspiracy
theories out there about
it was the pop-tarts that came after me
because i i
dared to do to dis mr kellogg himself
but
um i don't think that he's posthumously
attacking me from my intestines but you
never know
so i'll keep that in mind but uh thanks
and i'll keep you posted if there's any
changes okay
i'm gonna go nap now bye